I am an astronomic you know like that
guy rich Purnell in the movie the
Martian and it's my job to study and
predict motion of objects in space
currently we track about 1% of hazardous
objects on-orbit hazardous to services
like location agriculture banking
television and communications and soon
very soon even the Internet itself now
these services are not protected from
roughly half a million objects the size
of a speck of paint all the way to a
school bus in size a speck of paint
traveling at the right speed impacting
one of these objects could render it
absolutely useless but we can't track
things as small as a speck of paint we
can only track things as small as say a
smartphone so of this half million
objects that we should be concerned
about we can only track about 26,000 of
these objects and of these 26,000 only
2,000 actually work everything else is
garbage that's a lot of garbage to make
things a little bit worse
most of what we launched into orbit
never comes back we send the satellite
in orbit it stops working it runs out of
fuel and we send something else up and
then we send up something else and then
something else and every once in a while
two of these things will collide with
each other or one of these things will
explode or even worse somebody might
just happen to destroy one of their
satellites on orbit
and this generates many many more pieces
most of which also never come back now
these things are not just randomly
scattered in orbit it turns out that
given the curvature of space-time
they're ideal locations where we put
some of these satellites think of these
as space highways very much like
highways on earth these space highways
can only take up a maximum capacity of
traffic to sustain space safe operations
unlike highways on earth there are
actually no space traffic rules none
whatsoever okay Wow
what could possibly go wrong with that
now will be really nice is if we had
something like a space traffic map like
a ways for space that I could look up
and see what the current traffic
conditions are in space maybe even
predict these the problem with that
however is that ask five different
people what's going on in orbit where
are things going and you're probably
going to get ten different answers why
is that is because information about
things on orbit is not commonly shared
either so what if we had a globally
accessible open and transparent space
traffic information system that could
inform the public of where everything is
located to try to keep space safe and
sustainable and what if this system
could be used to form evidence-based
norms of behavior these space traffic
rules so I developed a stir graph the
world's first crowd-sourced space
traffic monitoring system at the
University of Texas at Austin Astraea
graph combines multiple sources of
information from around the globe
government industry in academia and
represents this in a common framework
that anybody can access today here you
can see 26,000 objects orbiting the
Earth multiple opinions and it gets
update
in near-real-time but back to my problem
of space traffic map what if you only
had information from the US government
well in that case that's what your space
traffic map would look like but what do
the Russians think that looks
significantly different who's right
who's wrong what should I believe what
could I trust this is part of the issue
in the absence of this framework to
monitor space actor behavior to monitor
activity in space where these objects
are located to reconcile these
inconsistencies and make this knowledge
commonplace we actually risk losing the
ability to use space for humanity's
benefit thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]